the low and no movement seems to be
really really gaining speed now why is
it that something that wasn't that good
for us is now only just beginning to
kind of get some momentum the only thing
I could speculate is that rise of sleep
trackers I think you really have some
objective data on the downside what is
happening inside of the body it's
causing that to happen one of the
metabolic byproducts of alcohol is quite
toxic the toxicity of that is changing
the autonomic nervous system what you
want to be doing when you're sleeping is
in a maximally parasympathetic State and
so heart rate goes up heart rate
variability goes down respiratory rate
goes up temperature goes up all of those
things happen when you drink that to me
is a very strong signal that something
about the toxicity of the metabolic
byproduct of ethanol is putting the body
into more of a fight or flight response
a thing that a lot of people use and has
been used for a long time I can't get to
sleep I'll have a glass of whiskey isn't
really aiding with sleep it's just
sedating people alcohol is very sedating
but it doesn't promote sleep